[موسيقى]
دبي في الصباح هو أفضل وقت
في اليوم.
الشمس تشرق للتو ولا يوجد أحد من حولي فقط
، والمحيط هو أكثر
شعور لا يصدق وهذا ما
يجعلني أستيقظ في الصباح ، اسمي دانيال
فان دورين وأنا  أحد
مؤسسي منزل ركوب الأمواج في دبي وأنا أعيش من أجل
ركوب الأمواج بالنسبة لي.
ملاذ صغير أساسًا
[موسيقى]
لذلك هذا هو شاطئ الطائرات الورقية عندما نشأت
هنا ، كان شاطئ الطائرات الورقية في الأساس قرية لصيد الأسماك
اعتاد الناس على الغوص بحثًا عن اللؤلؤ
أمرًا أساسيًا للغاية إذا نظرت إليه الآن
إنه مثل مكان في ميامي ،
لديك مطاعم ومقاهي  لديك
حدائق تزلج أي شيء تفعله
بالرياضات المائية ، لقد
تغير تمامًا الشيء المفضل لدي هنا
هو بالطبع ركوب الأمواج الذي
لا يربط الناس بدبي
كوجهة لركوب الأمواج ، نحصل على ما يقرب من 90 إلى
100 يوم من الأمواج القابلة للتصفح في العام
ولكن في الأيام  عندما يكون هناك  لا توجد نفايات ،
هناك الكثير من الخيارات اليوم ، نحن
ذاهبون لقد قمت بقيادة التزييت ،
هذا هو لوح التزلج الكهربائي الذي يمثل
أساسًا مستقبل رشاشات المياه ،
إنه لوح تزلج على الماء على جناح محلق
يسمح لك بالتحليق فوق الماء
بجنون أصفر حقًا ،
فلنذهب  استمتع
[الموسيقى]
في المرة الأولى التي جربت فيها هذه اللوحة
، شعرت
وكأنك تطير فوق الماء ، إنه شعور
لا مثيل له ، فهناك الكثير مما يمكنك القيام به
على السبورة ، حيث يمكنك القفز حيث يمكنك
ركوب الأمواج  يمكنك القيام بذلك على المياه المسطحة ،
إنه متعدد الاستخدامات حقًا ، أعتقد أن التسجيل
هو الصورة المثالية لدبي ، إنه
مستقبل الرياضات المائية وينقسم
دائمًا حول المستقبل ،
إنه أسلوب جهاز ركوب الأمواج الذي تعرف أن
الأشخاص يسافرون من جميع أنحاء
العالم ويتوقفون  ودبي لكنهم
لا يدركون أنه يمكنك بالفعل ركوب الأمواج
هنا ، فالكثير من الناس في الواقع
يعتبرون دبي كوجهة صحراوية ،
لكن لدينا
شواطئ رائعة وشواطئ رملية بيضاء والآن أصبح
شاطئ الطائرات الورقية جيدًا  لقد طورته
تشعر وكأنك في دبي ، فأنت لا تعرف
دبي لأنك كما لو كنت في هاواي أو
كاليفورنيا مع كل هذه
المطاعم وأنت تعرف أن الناس يمارسون رياضة ركوب الأمواج بالطائرة الورقية وركوب
الأمواج والتزلج مثل جوهرة خفية
في المنطقة